rot regiert wird Berlin regiert und wird
die Wahl heute die Verhältnisse
bestätigen oder verändern das ist die
große Frage Matthias wird sich auf jeden
Fall einiges verschieben ohne dass die
Verhältnisse sich zwingend ändern
müssten die CDU hat erstmals seit über
20 Jahren beste chancenstärkste Partei
zu werden eine Mehrheit zum Regieren
aber hat sie damit noch lange nicht denn
selbst wenn die FDP ist über die fünf
Prozent schafft reicht es bei weitem
nicht für Schwarz-Gelb und Schwarz-Grün
haben beide Seiten ziemlich klar
ausgeschlossen also könnte es
weitergehen wie bisher mit einer
Koalition aus SPD Grünen und Linken die
wird wohl wieder eine Mehrheit haben die
Befragten bewährten übrigens alle
Parteien hier schlecht und
dementsprechend keine mögliche Koalition
gut auch das sind Berliner Verhältnisse
also pünktlich um 18 Uhr wie immer die
Prognose bis dahin schauen wir noch mal
etwas genauer auf die Ausgangs sagen wir
zu dieser Wahl Chaos bei Verkehr und
Verwaltung Wohnungsmangel Kriminalität
werden die Wählerinnen und Wähler der
Politik hier die Quittung geben Matthias
Kubitza
Glücksspiel Berlin du sollst noch mal
wählen gehen Versuche rechtzeitig im
Wahllokal zu sein
alle zurück auf Los also
und Deutschland lästert die Hauptstadt
schmutzig chaotisch kaputt Berlin
ich glaube wir werden auf jeden Fall
schaffen ich wähle nicht weil ich eben
wirklich die Nase voll habe ich finde
auch in Berlin gibt es sehr viel Gutes
ganz ehrlich richtig viel Gutes
schließlich zieht es viele weiterhin her
Berlin wächst war noch nie so groß wie
heute doch auch die Probleme wachsen mit
Wohnungsmangel
soziale Ungleichheit das ist keine
Lehrer gibt es keine Erzieher gibt das
sind doch alles Dinge die man die fallen
nicht vom Himmel man weiße und so viele
Kinder sind geboren also weiß man wenn
die sechs sind kommen sie in die Schule
Alarm an vielen Orten Berlin kommt nicht
hinterher hier sehen Sie wie dreckig das
ist hier wird vieles geduldet das ist
das größte Problem und die Bürger
verzweifeln an der Verwaltung
drei Monate und das ist Katastrophe und
wenn Sie jetzt hier trainieren dann
sehen Sie das also ich habe probiert
über Telefonate
sinnlos und wie wird es weniger stressig
auf den Straßen vielleicht weniger
stürmische Fahrradfahrer aber das ist
jetzt vielleicht sehr kontrovers das
kann ich sein dass irgendwie ein paar
hundert Meter nur Fahrradstreifen da
gebaut wird und danach wieder kann man
vom Bus überfahren werden
Problemfeld Berlin mit
Ärger und Hürden an allen Ecken und
Enden wenigstens der Weg an die Wahlurne
sollte diesmal nicht zum Glücksspiel
werden
[Musik]
Stefan Merseburger ist der Leiter
unseres zdf-landesstudios Berlin Stefan
jetzt zuallererst mal die Frage ist denn
heute der Wahltag gut gegangen was sagen
die weibeobachter es war kein
Glücksspiel unsere Teams den ist nicht
so aufgefallen der Wahlleiter der
Landeswahlleiter ist zufrieden und auch
die internationalen Wahlbeobachter vom
europat die hier in die Stadt eingeladen
worden sind sind zufrieden also es
scheint als würde sich diese blamable
Katastrophe von 2021 nicht wiederholen
zum Glück also Berlin kann doch wählen
wie war denn die Stimmung im Wahlkampf
ein Winter Wahlkampf relativ kurz eine
Wahl Wiederholung stand hier irgendwie
ein Wechsel in der Luft also der
Wahlkampf war kurz eisig draußen man hat
gefroren eisiger Wind und in allen
Umfragen nicht nur in unseren liegt die
CDU mit Kai Wegner klar vorne die Frage
ist kann eine Mehrheit bauen ist der
oder ist am Ende doch ein König ohne
Land weil weder Franziska giffa noch
Bettina Jahres wollen ihm den Steigbügel
ins Rathaus so richtig halten Franziska
Giffey will das Rote Rathaus verteidigen
doch da muss sie mindestens an Platz
zwei landen damit das gelingen kann und
das ist sicherlich auch eine sehr
spannende Frage heute abend landet gif
vor Jahren ja oder nein und so hält
diese Wahl tatsächlich doch noch
spannendes bereit vielen dank Stefan wir
sehen dich später hier im
Abgeordnetenhaus natürlich wieder ja wir
sind wie immer an wahlabende natürlich
bei allen Parteien vertreten mit unseren
Reporterinnen und Reportern und wir
beginnen unseren schönen Reigen heute
bei der FDP um die 7%, das ist die
Größenordnung und jetzt Schneider heute
geht's erstmal überhaupt darum die Hürde
ins Abgeordnetenhaus zu nehmen
ja das ist das große Ziel der FDP hier
in Berlin wieder ins Abgeordnetenhaus zu
kommen die Umfragen der letzten Wochen
machen es ja sehr spannend und so ist
auch die Stimmung hier im Handel
genscherhaus in Berlin Mitte sehr sehr
gespannt die FDP hat den Wahlkampf vor
allem auf das Thema Verwaltungsreform
gesetzt klingt ein bisschen Tröger aber
das ist natürlich genau das was die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner nervt diese
langsame Verwaltung zweites Thema
Verkehr da will sie flexible Mobilität
und keine Verbote da Grenze sich von den
Grünen ab und es wird sich jetzt zeigen
ob diese Themen wirklich Reichen und
über 5% zu kommen und damit zurück ins
Wahlstudio
Nils vielen Dank weiter gehen wir zur
AFD die hier bei der Wahl 2016 aus dem
Stand auf gut 14% gekommen war dann
allerdings 2021 kräftig verloren bin der
Christan was rechnet sich die AFD heute
aus ja für die AFD in Berlin da soll es
einfach besser werden denn bei der Wahl
im Herbst 21 da war sie die große
Verliererin haben gerade mal auf 8%
Ergebnis fast halbiert heute Abend da
soll es wieder zweistellig werden ob das
klappt werden wir gleich sehen dennoch
ist ja schon jetzt klar wohin es mit der
AFD nach der Wahl geht nämlich in die
Opposition zwar träumt Spitzenkandidatin
Christin Brinker von einer
Regierungsbeteiligung irgendwann in der
Zukunft aber es mangelt in Berlin wie
auch in den anderen Ländern an möglichen
Partnern dennoch war dieser
zuversichtlich im Wahlkampf sie sagte an
den Fall der Mauer hat man auch nicht
geglaubt hier gegenüber Medienvertretern
in Berlin und damit zurück ins Studio
danke schön Linda und wir gehen weiter
zur Linken immer ein Faktor in der
Hauptstadt Berlin
Regierungspartei mit SPD und Grünen
Christina von Ungarn Sternberg die
Linken wollen hier ja auch weiter mit
regieren auch wenn ja der bundesgrenzung
gar nicht für sie spricht
und genau das ist das Problem Bettina
die Linken feiern hier mitten in
Kreuzberg in einem Kulturzentrum im
böcklerpark oben dreht sich schon die
dispokugel wie wir sehen aber was vor
allem über der Veranstaltung schwebt das
ist das s-wort es wie Sarah Wagenknecht
aber das ist ein ganz eigenes Kapitel
das bräuchte zu viel Zeit und das andere
ist es wie Schicksalswahl denn wir
erinnern uns bei der Bundestagswahl
hatte die Linke gerade mal fünf Prozent
und der Landesverband hier in Berlin ist
immer noch einer von denen gewesen die
relativ erfolgreich waren 14% hast du
schon gesagt bei der letzten
Abgeordnetenhauswahl und jetzt ist hier
die Frage kann man wieder so erfolgreich
sein und kann man hier weiter regieren
danke schön Christina das ist die Frage
eine linke Mehrheit auf die setzen
natürlich die Linken und lange war dann
hier die Frage wer für die an die
Kandidatin der SPD oder der Grünen mal
gucken wie knappes heute wird jetzt ist
aber erstmal die CDU in den Umfragen
stärkste Kraft geworden und die Frage
der Macht Option stellt sich ganz neu
ein Blick auf das Rennen der Parteien
und ihrer Spitzen Leute noch mal
Matthias Kubitza
Berlin du hast die Wahl vermasselt
wiederhole sie und zahle 39 Millionen
und gehe zurück auf Los bleibt das Rote
Rathaus in roter Hand Franziska Giffey
kämpft
will weiter Rot-Grün-Rot die SPD
wahrscheinlich stärker als die Grünen
aber umweltsenatorin jarasch nicht ohne
Chance
ich würde dieses Bündnis gerne
fortsetzen wollen gerne unter einer
grünenführung ja dass ich an der Stelle
anderer Meinung bin
versteht sich glaube ich von selbst doch
stärkste Kraft wird wohl die CDU auch
kein Wegner will das nächste Bündnis
bilden am liebsten eine zweierkoalition
mit der SPD
ich stehe für ein wirklichen
Politikwechsel während Wechsel will muss
diesmal CDU wählen und dann werden wir
Gespräche führen die Linke diesmal
schwächer als bei der letzten Wahl
im Parlament gewählt und am Ende wird es
Koalition geben und das die Linke da
stark wird und dann noch eine Rolle
spielt das ist mein Ziel für die FDP
könnte es knapp werden sie hofft auf ein
Bündnis mit CDU und SPD wir treten dafür
an bei dieser Wahl sieben bis acht
Prozent als Wahlergebnis tatsächlich in
eine solche reformkoalition mit
einbringen zu können mit der AFD will
niemand regieren ihr Ergebnis wohl
stärker als beim letzten Mal ich freue
mich über jedes Ergebnis was zweistellig
ist und das sieht auch gut danach aus
Berlin dreht eine extra Runde wer landet
in der Opposition und kann gefei im
Roten Rathaus bleiben
ja das gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal an
das Rennen an der Spitze zwischen den
dreien an der Spitze eines sehen wir ja
Matthias Franziska giffer ist es in den
anderthalb Jahren in denen sie jetzt
regiert hat nicht so richtig gelungen
einen Amtsbonus aufzubauen ja es ist
zwischen den dreien jedenfalls viel
enger als erwarteten das schauen wir uns
in der ersten Grafik hier mal an wenn
hätten sie am liebsten als Regierenden
Bürgermeister oder Bürgermeisterin in
Berlin die Amtsinhaberin Franziska
Giffey liegt vorne mit 32%, aber der
Abstand zu dem CDU-Spitzenkandidaten
kein Wegner ist nicht riesig etwas
abgeschlagen dagegen Bettina Jahres
diese 32 % sind deutlich kein Amtsbonus
und vergleicht man es mit den Werten von
Regierungschefs und Chefin den anderen
Ländern die kommen auf 70 und über 80%,
es ist ganz schwach jetzt gucken wir mal
woran das wo liegt die nächste Grafik
Franziska Franziska gifferl macht ihre
Sache eher gut das sagt eine knappe
Mehrheit von
51%, 40 %, aber sagen sie macht es
schlecht und hier auf der rechten Seite
sehen wir diese Balken die erklären das
dann nur die Anhänger der SPD scharen
sich hinter Giffey bei den anderen
bröckelt das so entsteht kann Amtsbonus
danke Matthias unsere wahre Porter
beobachten natürlich heute auch das
Rennen an der Spitze wir beginnen bei
den Grünen wo wo schmiese die Stellung
hält wohl im Politbarometer lagen die
Grünen zuletzt deutlich hinter der SPD
dass das jedenfalls wäre ein schlechtes
Zeugnis für die grüne Spitzenkandidatin
das stimmt Bettina zumal man ihr die
Schuld gibt dass die Grünen die im
Sommer noch Platz eins waren in den
Umfragen nun so abgeschmiert sind
aufgekratzt ist aber die Stimmung hier
bei der Heinrich Böll-Stiftung in Berlin
Mitte weil ein bisschen die Hoffnung
keimt man könnte Platz 2 zumindest doch
noch erreichen dann kommt aber ein oh
Gott das würde ja bedeuten schwarz grün
könnte Thema werden und das ist vielen
grünen schwer zu vermitteln danke Wolf
das ist in der Tat schon ein
interessante Ausblick in den Abend eine
der möglichen Diskussionen in den
letzten Umfragen ist die CDU nämlich an
SPD und Grünen vorbeigezogen und könnte
somit heute stärkste Kraft werden in
Berlin seit 1999 war das nicht mehr der
Fall die Ferien die Frage wird dann sein
wohin mit all der Kraft das wird die
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon diskutiert
oder absolut Bettina 1999 kam die Partei
übrigens auf über 40%, das ist heute
vermutlich utopisch aber die sechs
Flaschen stehen auf jeden Fall schon
kalt
ein besseres berlines möglich heißt es
auf den Wahlplakaten und diesmal soll es
für die CDU nicht nur besser sondern
bestens laufen die Partei will die Nase
vorn haben und zwar deutlich denn
CDU-Spitzenkandidat Kai Wegner möchte
wir sagt eine
modernisierungskoalition im Roten
Rathaus anführen fragt sich allerdings
mit wem außer der FDP hat bereits keine
Partei die Hand gehoben und die Grünen
haben klar abgewunken also am Ende muss
man sehen ob Kai Wegner weil Sieger wird
und dann doch womöglich als Verlierer
vom Platz geht ja vielen Dank dann zur
SPD die hier heute bestätigt werden will
Ralf stepanski Franziska giffer will
Regierende Bürgermeisterin bleiben dafür
müsste sie aber mindestens mal Platz
zwei erobern wie ist die Stimmung
die Stimmung um es kurz zu machen ist
gut die SPD will feiern hat sich hier
eine lässige location in Kreuzberg
rausgesucht die Optionen liegen auf der
Hand zur Not hinter der CDU aber auf
jeden Fall vor den Grünen zu landen das
ist hier die Losung heute Abend in einer
Minute bis wir mehr gespannt sind alle
danke schön Ralf stepanski so und das
war jetzt schon der Blick in die
Ausgangslage wir fassen das noch mal
zusammen genau 25 Sekunden bis zur
Prognose um 18 Uhr eine Wahlwiederholung
die aber doch spannend zu werden
verspricht worauf müssen Sie jetzt
achten bei der Prognose wie weit kann
die CDU enteilen den anderen Parteien
denn sie liegt in allen Umfragen vorne
und dann natürlich schauen wie
naheliegen SPD und Grüne beieinander die
Prognose in drei Sekunden
[Musik]
SPD 18 Prozent das sind 3,4
Prozentpunkte weniger im Vergleich zu
2021 CDU 28 Prozent plus 10 grüne 18 -
0,9 linke 13 - 1,1 die AFD 9 damit
einstellig plus eins die FDP 5 das sind
Verluste und es ist wirklich völlig
unsicher ob sie den Einzug ins
Abgeordnetenhaus schafft die anderen
zusammen bei 9 und was das jetzt
bedeutet für die Sitzverteilung und für
mögliche Koalitionen das von Matthias
vorne auf sehr gerne das schauen wir uns
jetzt gleich an die Prognose zur
Sitzverteilung 130 sitze ist das Minimum
im Abgeordnetenhaus es werden im Laufe
des Abends
Überhangmandate und Ausgleichsmandate
dazu kommen das verändert aber nicht das
Kräfteverhältnis der Parteien jetzt
gehen wir erstmal durch die SP das Thema
auf 26 Sitze CDU 40 grüne 26 linke 18
AFD 13 und die FDP wenn sie es denn
Knappschaft auf 7 Sitze was heißt das
für die Möglichkeiten zur
Regierungsbildung für die Koalition hier
sehen wir diese senkrechte Linie 66
Sitze da muss man drüber wegkommen das
amtierende Bündnis von SPD GRÜNEN und
Linke hat das mit 70 sitzen egal ob nun
die SPD oder die Grünen zweitstärkste
Kraft werden eine große Koalition CDU
geführt mit der SPD ganz knapp drunter
und das gleiche gilt für CDU und grün
oder sie würden genau erreichen mit 66
sitzen das ist haarscharf es würde aber
eben knapp reichen auch wenn die FDP
reinkäme und noch ein Blick auf die
Wahlbeteiligung da sehen wir hier ganz
rechts die Wahlbeteiligung von heute wir
gehen jetzt mal einmal durch die ist bei
65% deutlich schlechter als vor
anderthalb Jahren da war aber parallel
Bundestagswahl aber auch noch schlechter
als 2016
über 66,9 Prozent
ja Dankeschön Matthias das war in der
Tat zu erwarten jetzt schauen wir noch
mal auf dieses Ergebnis der Wahlsieger
des Abends heißt Kai Wegner die CDU
kommt auf 28 Gewinne von zehn
Prozentpunkten und auch zehn
Prozentpunkte über der SPD die Fehring
bei der CDU da wird wahrscheinlich immer
noch gejubelt oder
ja die Stimmung hier bei der CDU Bettina
war schon vor der 18 Uhr zuversichtlich
aber jetzt liegt die CDU tatsächlich so
weit vorne da ist die Stimmung gekommen
zu halten ein riesen Jubel ging ja durch
den Saal die Leute lagen sich in den
Armen ich kann hier kaum mein eigenes
Wort verstehen also die Freude ist hier
natürlich diesen groß und für die CDU
steht fest jetzt wird kein Weg bei der
Regierungsbildung an der CDU vorbei der
Druck auf die anderen Parteien wächst
die Berlinerinnen und Berliner so sieht
das hier die zu wollen jetzt klar den
Weg wechseln aber ob das die anderen
Parteien tatsächlich auch so sehen oder
ob kein Weg am Ende dann doch ein
Kündigung ohne Landwirt das wird sich
zeigen ich habe gehört dass er ja ganz
in der Nähe die ersten Zahlen verfolgt
und auch gleich hier in den
fraktionszeit kommen wird und hier wird
er sicherlich dann von seiner eigenen
Partei erstmal königlich empfangen
werden das wird so sein dann sind wir
wieder bei Euch vielen Dank für diese
ersten Eindrücke und in der Tat wenn es
für kein Wegner zu einem zweier Bündnis
reichen würde dann wird natürlich der
Druck auf die anderen Parteien um so
größer und jetzt gehen wir direkt auch
zur SPD denn da wollen wir hören wie die
wie dieses Ergebnis 18 Prozent in der
Prognose und im Moment nicht einmal vor
den Grünen aufgenommen wurde
wahrscheinlich mit Enttäuschung
einer Minute schon vorbei war
gut ich glaube jetzt sind wir dran okay
also Bettina selten erlebt dass eine
Party das ist eine Party nach einer
Minute schon vorbei war und wir haben
hier die Bilder gesehen es ist
Schockstarre die Minen versteinert
insofern ganz klar zu sagen man hat ja
vielleicht damit gerechnet hinter der
CDU zu liegen aber das ist so schlecht
ist dass man so weit hinter der CDU
liegt damit war nicht zu rechnen und
insofern ist die Frage durchaus laut zu
stellen heute abend ob man mit dem
abstehen und hinter der CDU wirklich so
weitermachen kann und wirklich glauben
kann ein linkes Bündnis noch aufrecht
erhalten zu können danke schön für die
Eindrücke und sie haben ihn gerade schon
gesehen Kevin Kühnert steht uns zu einem
kurzen Gespräch zur Verfügung der
spd-generalsekretär schönen guten Abend
Herr Kühnert wir können diese Frage in
der Tat gleich weitergehen nach mehr als
20 Jahren verliert die SPD den
Spitzenplatz in Berlin wie sehr das
zunächst mal gefragt schmerzt Sie diese
doch bittere Niederlage
ja selbstverständlich schmerzt das es
ist jetzt noch zu früh am Abend um schon
alle Antworten zu haben aber klar ist in
der Tendenz die CDU wird heute Abend
stärkste Kraft sein dazu ist ihr zu
gratulieren dabei ist die Maus überhaupt
gar kein Faden ab und das ist nicht das
Ergebnis was die SPD sich gewünscht hat
der CDU ist es gelungen in diesem
Wahlkampf einen Nerv zu treffen bei
einem Teil der Menschen in der Stadt das
habe ich persönlich das haben wir alle
in der SPD sehr deutlich in diesem
Wahlkampf wahrgenommen und das muss auch
die Konsequenz aus dieser Wahl sein dass
in zentralen Bereichen des politischen
Geschehens und das Verwaltungs Handelns
natürlich ist kein weiter so geben darf
sondern dass es auch eine Lehre aus
dieser Wahl geben muss egal wie sich die
politischen Mehrheiten am Ende
zusammenfinden werden ja die leeren
werden gezogen werden müssen denn im
Moment sieht es so aus dass Franziska
Giffey nicht zweite klar Zweite geworden
ist was bisher erwartet wurde die Grünen
sind stärker im Moment in den Prognosen
gleich auf
ein Hinweis dann doch gefragt kann
Franziska Giffey damit für sich die
Regierungsbildung oder gar die
Fortsetzung ihrer Regierung überhaupt
beanspruchen
wir werden jetzt im weiteren Abende
erstmal abwarten müssen wie die Zahlen
sich entwickeln ich erinnere an die
Abgeordnetenhauswahl vor anderthalb
Jahren da sah es anfangs auch ganz
anders aus als es schlussendlich
ausgegangen ist also der Respekt vor den
Wählerinnen und Wählern erfordert das
glaube ich dass wir jetzt nicht schon
ins Blaue hinein kommentieren sondern
ein bisschen auch abwarten klar ist aber
wer regieren möchte am Ende in Berlin
der muss einem Mehrheit hinter sich
versammeln zum Regierungsgeschäft gehört
eben auch dass man Widersprüche und
unterschiedliches unter einen Hut
bringen kann und Kai Wegner und die CDU
bei einem Respekt vor dem heutigen
Ergebnis haben einen Wahlkampf geführt
der sehr stark auf das Trennende gesetzt
hat man wollte das System SPD beenden
mit den Grünen nicht zusammenarbeiten
und insofern wird man auch sehen müssen
welche demokratischen Kräfte überhaupt
bereit willens und in der Lage sind das
einen der das Zusammenarbeiten zu suchen
franziska hat das in der Vergangenheit
getan und ich verrate keine Geheimnisse
wenn ich sage wir wünschen uns in der
SPD das sieht es weiterhin tun kann
dafür haben wir diesen Wahlkampf gemacht
dass sie Regierende Bürgermeisterin
bleiben kann gut
mal als ersten Hinweis Dankeschön Kevin
kühner der SPD Generalsekretär so dann
jetzt mal zu den Grünen da deutete es
sich schon an zu Wulff schmieser die
Grünen gleich auf mit der SPD und das
heißt natürlich auch durchaus noch
hoffen
ja wir Tina die Grünen sind hier ganz
aus dem Häuschen für die mögliche
Silbermedaille Platz 2 scheint offenbar
über den Hoffnungen zu sein die man
hatte das heißt und das war auch
interessant es wurde einerseits gejubelt
dass es für Schwarz-Grün reichen konnte
manche Sachen aber auch ob das wirklich
Grund für Jubel ist und es wurde gebucht
als es für Schwarz Rot reichte auf der
Tortengrafik also große Freude über den
möglichen Platz zwei noch ist alles
offen und ähm na ja möglicherweise eine
schwarz-grüne Zukunft oder keine als
Regierungspartei danach aus
ja wohl vielen Dank für diese Einordnung
da haben die Grünen viele Diskussionen
vermutlich vor sich und wir können jetzt
auch bereits sprechen mit Ricarda lang
der Grünen Bundesvorsitzenden die ich
herzlich begrüße ja was macht man jetzt
daraus werden sich die Grünen Gesprächen
mit der CDU verschließen oder werden sie
sie selbstbewusst und offen führen
ja erstmal ist ja gerade noch
unglaublich viel offen insbesondere ist
das Rennen um Platz zwei noch offen wir
gratulieren der CDU zu ihrem sehr guten
Ergebnis wir freuen uns dass wir ein
starkes Ergebnis haben es sieht so aus
als könnten wir es bisher beste von der
letzten Wahl vielleicht stabilisieren
und wir sehen das als Auftrag was
bezahlbares Wohnen was Klimaschutz in
Berlin angeht und werden in diese
Richtung natürlich in den nächsten Tagen
Gespräche mit den demokratischen
Parteien führen klar mit dem Ziel es
braucht schnell eine Regierung in Berlin
die sich um die Probleme der Menschen
kümmert und dafür braucht es
parlamentarische Mehrheiten die Frage
ist noch mal die der Offenheit im
Wahlkampf war die Mauer sehr hoch
zwischen CDU und Grünen ähm gebietet es
jetzt nicht einfach auch ganz schlecht
vor lauter Jubel die Frage ist noch mal
die der Offenheit die Ablehnung der
Grünen gegenüber der CDU war ja sehr
stark schiebt man das jetzt beiseite und
sagt gut also im Grunde muss man offen
auch Richtung schwarz grün handeln
natürlich stehen für Gespräche mit den
demokratischen Parteien zur Verfügung
das war nach jeder Wahl so und das wird
auch nach dieser Wahl zu sein wir haben
unsere Präferenzen Vorhinein sehr klar
gemacht bisher ist die Frage wer die
Poleposition innerhalb des progressiven
Lagers hat noch offen das wird sich
denke ich erst im Laufe des Abends
entscheiden am Ende geht es für uns aber
darum was wir inhaltlich umsetzen können
denn wir sind in den Wahlkampf gezogen
mit einem klaren inhaltlichen Angebot
und zwar Veränderungen zu gestalten um
damit am Ende Sicherheit zu geben also
Klimaneutralität in dieser Stadt zu
schaffen den Wohlstand damit zu sichern
und gleichzeitig bezahlbare Mieten und
soziale Sicherheit und daran werden wir
uns auch orientieren wenn es ein
Koalitionsverhandlungen geht ich glaube
jegliche Festlegungen werden bei diesen
volatilen Ergebnissen wenn Sie diese
frühen Zeit gerade fehl am Platz nein
aber zwischen Töne sind auch schon
interessant Ricarda lang die Grünen
Bundesvorsitzende herzlichen Dank von
der Wahlparty der Grünen die noch hoffen
hier vielleicht sogar die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin stellen zu können jetzt
höre ich das Franziska Giffey bereit
sich ihren Wahlleuten stellt da haben
wir rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieser Abend
ist einer in dem wir zuerst mal danke an
Euch alle sagen
ist einer der auch nicht leicht ist
es ist eine an dem wir sagen können die
SPD hat im letzten Jahr in einer
krisenhaften Zeit in einer schwierigen
Situation in einem Wahlkampf der ein
ausnahmewahlkampf war alles gegeben alle
Kraft ihr wart draußen ihr habt gekämpft
wir haben zusammen gekämpft und wir sind
jetzt in einer Situation wo wir sagen
müssen es ist nicht Platz 1 geworden und
wir wissen noch nicht ob es Platz 2
geworden ist
wir müssen ganz klar sehen dieses
Ergebnis ist eins was zeigt die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner sind nicht
zufrieden mit dem wir es jetzt ist sie
wünschen sich das Dinge anders werden
und wir haben nur ein Jahr Zeit gehabt
um auch Weichen zu stellen damit Dinge
anders werden können
und ein Jahr ist kurz wenn man drei
Krisen gleichzeitig bewältigt und eine
Wahlwiederholung hat die wir uns alle
nicht gewünscht haben mit der wir aber
umgehen mussten
und das bedeutet dass wir heute an einem
Punkt sind wo wir ganz klar sagen müssen
die CDU ist offensichtlich stärkste
Kraft geworden das müssen wir anerkennen
und das bedeutet
dass wir auf der anderen Seite
schauen müssen was was heißt das für uns
und unser Ziel war und ist es
stärkste Kraft in dieser Landesregierung
zu werden
und das bedeutet dass derjenige der mit
dem stärksten Wahlergebnis hier heute
abend rausgegangen ist jeder der in
diesem Land regieren will muss es
schaffen eine stabile politische
Mehrheit zu organisieren und das ist
deine Frage wie für uns jetzt auch
relevant ist
Franziska Giffey die schon angefasst
klingt aber nicht die segelstreicht
sondern darauf hinweist dass man eben
auch eine Regierungsmehrheit braucht die
rot-grün rot noch hat oder grün rot rot
jetzt aber zur CDU denn der
Spitzenkandidat und Wahlsieger des
heutigen Abends kein Wegner stellt sich
jetzt auch schon sein Parteifreunden
[Applaus]
ja kann ich machen
ja kein Weg in der Spitzenkandidat der
CDU ist jetzt hier auf die Bühne
gekommen der Jubel ist gigantisch so
dein Spalier gebildet dass kein Wegner
hier auf die Bühne kommt da die Nase
haben sie soweit vor den CDU sie wollen
auf keinen Fall das noch einen Weg an
der CDU jetzt bei der Regierungsbildung
vorbei wird dass kein Wegner König und
Landwirt hier wird er auf jeden Fall
königlich empfangen die Begeisterung des
riesengroß
mit dem auf der Bühne steht
und wir hören jetzt mal rein was er zu
sagen hat
vielen vielen Dank
mir fehlen ein Stück weit die Worte
es ist phänomenal
und ich kann nur sagen
Berlin hat den Wechsel gewählt
[Applaus]
wir haben das auf den Straßen in den
letzten Wochen
die Menschen wollen einen politischen
Wechsel und dieser Wechsel drückt sich
nun auch in den Zahlen aus
und deswegen danke ich erstmal
allen
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten
den vielen ehrenamtlichen engagierten
die von morgens bis abends unsere
Kampagne auf die Straße gebracht haben
ich danke auch
ich danke auch den vielen Wahlhelfern
die heute dafür gesorgt haben dass die
Wahl
ordnungsgemäß verlaufen ist und wir ein
neues Abgeordnetenhaus wählen konnten
was demokratisch legitimiert ist und ich
danke vor allen Dingen unseren
Wählerinnen und Wählern
herzlichen Dank für diesen klaren
Regierungsauftrag
wir sind angetreten mit dem klaren Motto
wir wollen das Berlin funktioniert
und ich sage euch wir wollen auch dafür
sorgen dass diese Stadt wieder
zusammengeführt wird dass wir Schluss
machen mit dem gegeneinander Fahrrad
gegen Auto Innenstadt gegen Außenbezirke
alt gegen jung wir wollen dafür sorgen
dass diese Stadt zusammengeführt wird
wir wollen die ganze Stadt in den Blick
nehmen und unser Auftrag ist es jetzt
und den haben uns die Wählerinnen und
Wähler gegeben unser Auftrag ist es
jetzt eine stabile Regierung zu bilden
eine Regierung die
vertrauensvoll
zusammenarbeitet wo man den Partner auch
Erfolge gönnt und wir wollen eine
Regierung bilden die wirklich anpackt
die die Probleme löst die Berlin hat und
wir wollen eine erfolgreiche
berlin-koalition anführen liebe Freunde
dafür werden wir in den nächsten Tagen
Gespräche führen
bei Wegner der Spitzenkandidat der CDU
und Wahlsieger des heutigen Abends plus
10 für die CDU die mit 28 Prozent jetzt
in der Prognose aus dieser Wahl
hervorgegangen ist und erhebt ganz klar
den regierungsanspruch Berlin hat den
Wechsel gewählt sagt Kai Wegner wir
können mal schauen Matthias woher kommen
die zu gewinnen für die CDU ja das sind
ja ungefähr zehn Punkte das ist
unheimlich viel zu 2021 und deshalb
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an woher
kommen die Wähler der CDU von denen die
diesmal als CDU gewählt haben haben 2021
SPD gewählt 14% in absoluten Zahlen etwa
60.000 und von der FDP sind es immer
noch 10% und 45000 das ist besonders
bitter für die Liberalen das könnte in
den Einzug ins Abgeordnetenhaus kosten
aber man sieht auf jeden Fall
gucken das bis unten durch auch von
anderen 70.000 die CDU hat es geschafft
aus verschiedenen Ecken Stimmen auf sich
zu
ja für die FDP könnte das noch bitter
enden denn sie ist noch auf der Kippe
jetzt können wir aber auch schon eine
bundespolitische Stimme der CDU hören
ich begrüße Mario Czaja im
Konrad-Adenauer-Haus CDU-Generalsekretär
schönen guten Abend Herr Chaya und man
sieht es ihnen schon an sie sind im
Glück die CDU ist stärkste Kraft in
Berlin das gelang zuletzt 1999 also ein
sehr erfolgreicher Abend aber kein
Wegner hat die Mehrheit die Macht Option
bisher nicht was fängt die CDU nun an
mit dieser neuen Stärke
Berlin hat einen Neuanfang gewählt und
Kai Wegener hat mit der Berliner CDU
einen fantastisches Ergebnis herum seit
einem Vierteljahrhundert sind wir wieder
stärkste Kraft in dieser
Bundeshauptstadt und das ist ein tolles
Ergebnis hat den klaren
Regierungsauftrag und der wird diesen
Regierungsauftrag sicherlich auch sehr
vernünftig mit den anderen Parteien
besprechen berlin braucht eine stabiler
Regierung die nicht das gegeneinander
sondern das Miteinander lebt die
Außenstadt und Innenstadt zusammenbringt
die fahrradfahrer und Autofahrer nicht
gegeneinander ausspielt Kabine hat die
Punkte eben genannt wir haben gut
zusammengearbeitet zwischen Bundespartei
und Landespartei der Regierungsauftrag
ist da ein Neuanfang für Berlin ist
möglich und es ist jetzt seine Aufgabe
Sondierungsgespräch mit den anderen
Parteien zu führen um das stabile
Regierung für Berlin zu bekommen und ich
bin mir sicher dass das auch gelingen
kann die Frage ist nur die anderen damit
machen denn es gibt eine linke Mehrheit
in dieser Stadt hat Kai Wegner am Ende
versäumt doch auch schon im Wahl das
entsprechende Signale zu geben und sich
nicht nur
abzugrenzen von Grünen und SPD
Herr Wegener hat im Wahlkampf sehr
deutlich gemacht wofür die Berliner CDU
steht und was mit der CDU zu machen ist
und was nicht mit der CDU zu machen ist
und dafür hat er auch ein sehr starkes
Wahlergebnis erhungen und es gehört zu
Wahlkämpfen dazu dass man sagt wofür man
steht welche Position man hat und was
mit einem nicht geht und das ein
Gegeneinander nicht geht sondern nur ein
Miteinander geht und dafür hat er einen
klaren Regierungsauftrag erhalten es
wäre ausgesprochen unanständig wenn
jetzt diese Regierung den Eindruck
erwecken würde sie können in dieser Form
weitermachen die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner haben ein klares Zeichen
gesetzt und Kai Wegner wird das sehr
verantwortungsbewusst wahrnehmen mit den
anderen Parteien sprechen und ich bin
mir sicher dass dann auch unter seiner
Führung eine schnelle stabile gute
Regierung für Berlin gebildet werden
kann sie sagen unanständig wenn die
anderen eine Mehrheit bilden und hat die
Berliner CDU schon von wahlklau
gesprochen schließen sie sich da an
der Regierungsauftrag ist klar bei Kai
Wegner ein so deutliches Ergebnis dass
die Berlinerinnen und Berliner hier
gegeben haben macht doch klar die wir
Stadt hat den Wechsel gewählt die Stadt
hat den Neuanfang gewählt die Stadt hat
eine Regierung unter der Führung von Kai
Weg wir haben eben auch schon Franziska
Giffey gehört die ähnliches gesagt hat
der Regierungsauftrag liegt im Grunde
nach bei uns und die anderen Parteien
werden jetzt Gespräche mit uns führen
natürlich muss man in
Koalitionsverhandlungen miteinander
sprechen was möglich ist und welche
Position man hat aber es ist eben auch
klar was die Berlinerinnen und Berliner
sich wünschen und dieses ist sehr
deutlich geworden sie wünschen sich eine
Führung der CDU sie wünschen sich kein
Wegner zum Regierenden Bürgermeister
sagt der CDU-Generalsekretär Mario
herzlichen Dank
so und wir schauen jetzt noch mal auf
die linke 13% in der Prognose das sind
ganz leichte Verluste nur kann man fast
sagen denn im Bund ist die Linke derzeit
schwach in Berlin regiert sie mit wir
schauen mal zu Christina von Ungarn
Sternberg wie ist die Stimmung wie wurde
das Wahlergebnis ausgenommen die Linke
will ja auf jeden Fall weiter mit Rot
und Grün regieren
ja Bettina die Frage nach der Stimmung
lässt sich schnell beantworten und hören
die djen auf
zögerlich als die Zahlen gerade kamen
dann war der Jubel groß bei den eigenen
Zahlen
man war Verhalten natürlich große Buche
bei der CDU bei den CDU Zahlen bei den
eigenen großer Jubel und dann auch noch
mal Jubel als klar war dass die FDP
wackelt ich habe gerade mit dem
Spitzenkandidaten gesprochen Klaus
Lehrer der sagt ihm fällt ein Stein vom
Herzen denn sie haben offenbar auf die
richtigen Themen gesetzt und sie haben
es geschafft sich vom Trend im Bund
abzusetzen jetzt ist die Frage was macht
man damit und wie wird sie den Abend
hier noch beschäftigen die Linken also
heißt es hier in böcklerpark so lange
abwarten und club-matete trinken
Christina vielen Dank für diese
Eindrücke und bei mir ist katja Kipping
Senatorin hier in Berlin für Arbeit und
Soziales und lange Jahre
Bundesvorsitzende der Linken deshalb
natürlich umso eine umso interessantere
Gesprächspartnerin Frau Kipping sie
sehen das vermutlich auch so gut
abgeschnitten die Linke jetzt sagt aber
der Herr Wegner Berlin hat den Wechsel
gewählt sehen Sie das auch so
also zum einen der Berliner linke klar
zweistellig ich freue mich und sag
einfach Danke bei allen Wahlkämpfen und
allen wählenden und zu der Aussage von
Kai Wegner kann ich nur sagen also es
gibt nach jetzigen Stand der Ergebnisse
klare soziale Mehrheiten in Berliner
Parlament und in dieser Zeit braucht es
das auch und wer Berlin was Gutes will
kann einfach nicht wollen dass die
Truppe von Kai Wegner über die Zukunft
des Sozialtickets entscheidet über die
Zukunft von bezahlbaren wohnen oder am
Ende sogar die Herausforderung der
Flüchtlingsbewegung hier bewältigt aber
das sagt sagen sie als Linker aber das
sehen vielleicht SPD und Grüne anders
auf die natürlich jetzt der politische
Druck wächst vor allem dann auch wenn es
zu zweier Kombination reichen würde bin
aber man muss ja auch immer schauen was
ist die Konsequenz davon weil zum einen
würde jeder der sich jetzt für ein
Bündnis mit der Union entscheidet ganz
klar die Chance auf soziale Mehrheiten
verspielen und er würde zugleich im
Bundesrat die unsoziale und die
unökologische weh tun macht von
Friedrich Merz erhöhen da kann man Kleid
tschüss zum Klimaschutz und Tschüss zur
Kindergrundsicherung sagen würde ich SPD
und grün nicht empfehlen sie empfehlen
weiter so dass wundert uns den Einsatz
für Soziales empfehle ich nicht einfach
ein weiter so man kann auch aus Fehlern
noch besser werden katja Kipping vielen
Dank sie setzt auf eine Fortsetzung der
bisherigen Regierung Dankeschön für den
Besuch und wir hören jetzt wir haben
eine Hochrechnung die haben wir uns
sehen wir uns erstmal an so sieht's aus
hier kommt die erste Hochrechnung
18:25 Uhr demnach kommt die SPD auf 18,1
Prozent mit deutlichen Verlusten
gegenüber 2021 die CDU auf 27,8 mit
knapp 10 Punkten zu gewinnen die Grünen
bei 18,1% und wenig Verlusten die Linke
bei 12,8% auch mit leichten Verlusten
die AFD bei 9% und einem Punkt zu
gewinnen und die FDP nach wie vor knapp
um die 5% Hürde andere 9,2 insgesamt
jetzt schauen wir mal auf der
Sitzverteilung im Abgeordnetenhaus
130 Sitze wird es mindestens geben am
Ende des Tages wahrscheinlich mehr aber
das tangiert nicht das Kräfteverhältnis
der Parteien die SPD 26 Sitze die CDU 40
grüne 26 linke 18
AFD 13 und die FDP wenn sie denn drin
ist wären das siebensitze wer könnte da
mit wem reagieren
wir sehen hier die absolute Mehrheit bei
66 sitzen das reicht wie gerade schon
gehört für SPD Grüne und Linke in jedem
Fall egal ob grüne oder SPD am Ende
stärker sein werden reicht es auch für
CDU und SPD ja knapp und es reicht auch
für CDU und Grüne auch wenn das bisher
politische immer ausgeschlossen wurde
genauso knapp die erreichen genau die
nötigen 66 das heißt derzeit unabhängig
davon ob die FDP drin ist oder nicht
reicht es auch für diese zweier
Kollektion ja danke schön Matthias also
kein guter Abend für die FDP unsicher ob
sie überhaupt drin ist aber selbst wenn
sie drin wäre könnte es auch für andere
Konstellationen reichen deshalb schauen
wir jetzt mal eben zur FDP und Nils
Schneider wie das Ergebnis dort
diskutiert wird
sie hatten sich sieben acht Prozent
vorgenommen jetzt ist noch nicht klar ob
sie reinkommen damit ja das ist jetzt
ein langer Abend natürlich ist man als
Wahlkämpfer an so einem Abend dann auch
schon mal erleichtert da wenn es
stabiler ist die Prognose ist im
Augenblick bei 5 insoweit heißt es jetzt
in den nächsten Stunden noch abwarten
bis die weiteren Auszählungsergebnisse
dazu kommen sie haben für eine
reformkoalition mit der CDU beworben in
den letzten Tagen ist das hat ihnen das
eher genutzt oder geschadet ist das
jetzt eine Möglichkeit
ja die CDU ist der klare Wahlgewinner an
dieser Stelle auch mein Glückwunsch an
die Union die nunmehr den Auftrag hat
eine Koalition zu bilden und wenn man
sich die Situation anschaut dann werden
wir durchaus auch für diese Frage
gebraucht werden aber am Ende werden wir
sehen ob das Wahlergebnis dafür
ausreichend ist und Berlin entsprechend
gewählt hat eine Frage noch was glauben
Sie warum hat der Wahlkampf nicht so
gezogen wie erhofft
ich glaube das kann man jetzt noch gar
nicht sagen insbesondere mit Blick auf
die Fragen der Themen was war am Ende
für die Berliner und Berliner Wahl
entscheiden ging es ausschließlich um
den politischen Wechsel an der Spitze
ein klarer Vorsprung der Union den wir
jetzt sehen oder ging es um die Frage
anderer Konstellation das muss man sich
in Ruhe anschauen das werden wir aber
dann auch in den morgigen und übermorgen
in die Gremien machen vielen Dank
ja das also die Stimmung bei der FDP
unsicher ob sie in das Abgeordnetenhaus
einzieht wir schauen mal auf das erste
hochrechnungsergebnis der AFD 9 Prozent
darüber können wir jetzt schon sprechen
mit hinopalla dem Kopf Vorsitzenden der
Bundespartei Herr Koala das ist etwas
besser als 21 allerdings doch noch
relativ weit entfernt von dem was sie
2016 hier hatten mit 14%, meine Frage
wäre warum
konnten sie da offenbar das Potenzial
nicht ausschöpfen sind im Grunde dann
doch alle zu CDU gegangen die dass die
bessere Alternative fanden nein es gibt
diesen Abend zwei Sieger das muss man
klar sagen dass die CDU ist die AFD und
die CDU hat die protest-wähler die von
denen wir ja häufiger profitieren
abgezogen aber natürlich ist hier ganz
klar dass diese Stadt sich klar gegen
rot rot grün gewarnt hat das ist zu
begrüßen und das natürlich auch ein
Stück weit in Finger zeigt gegen den
Bundestrend oder bin gegen diese
Bundesregierung mit ihren falschen Kurs
bieten sie sich da Kai Wegner gerade an
der ja schon ausgeschlossen hat mit
ihnen zu koordinieren zu kommen wir
erreichen allen die Hennen wir wollen
mit allen demokratischen Parteien
natürlich ins Gespräch kommen natürlich
jetzt will ich doch noch mal fragen sie
laden hier schon mal schon mal besser wo
wie erklären sie das sozusagen sie
hätten ja jetzt den
Vertrauensverlust den man jetzt auch
sieht an diesem Abend gegenüber
Rot-Grün-Rot stärker nutzen können um
voranzukommen warum ist das nicht
gelungen in die Vergangenheit ich schaue
immer in die Zukunft und wir haben jetzt
bei dieser Wahl die natürlich auch einen
kurzen intensiven Wahlkampf beinhaltet
hat mit Christian Brinker als Spitzen
kann ihn zugelegt das ist erstmal sehr
positiv warten wir mal den weiteren
Abend ab insgesamt muss man sagen dass
wir natürlich mit unserer Politik hier
in Berlin auch schwierige Verhältnisse
haben hier ist es Brennglas äh der
Republik und wir werden hier natürlich
konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit machen es ist wichtig
das ist ein Korrektiv in diesem
Stadtparlament gibt das hat ja die
Vergangenheit gezeigt denn wir haben ja
auch dazu beigetragen dass diese Wahl
nach diesem Motion allein auch
wiederholt wurde wir werden sehen wie
sie die Oppositionsarbeit gestalten Tino
propala herzlichen Dank für den Besuch
im Studio so und jetzt könnten wir an
dieser Stelle tatsächlich mal kurz 18
Uhr 30 tun wir das gerne mal in kurzen
Strich runterziehen was haben wir bisher
erlebt Professor Karl Rudolf kortis wie
immer bei uns natürlich und wir gehen
mal in eine kurze Runde der Analyse ich
glaube man kann sagen jedenfalls
spannender also eine Wiederholungswahl
es vermuten ließ das war ja beginnt
absolut spektakulär vermutlicher die
Möglichkeit besteht für ein
Regierungswechsel wenngleich eine
Ähnlichkeit darin besteht dass die
politische Mitte beständig bleibt sich
geradezu ausbaut und dass es in diesen
Krisenzeiten ungefähr ein Jahr nach
Kriegseintritt auch etwas als deutsche
Besonderheit des Wählens
gleichwohl sehen wir eine Schwäche der
SPD mit leichten Verlusten und
deutlichem Abstand zur CDU
man hat den Eindruck die Kritiker dieses
Senat sind zur CDU gegangen die die den
erhalten wollten am Grünen gewählt also
da ist die SPD ein bisschen in die
Zwickmühle geraten ja und das ist
offenbar eine Wechselstimmung so gewesen
dass man mit dieser Unzufriedenheit die
an der Regierung hier existiert vor
allem die SPD abgestraft hat es ist
nicht ungewöhnlich dass man die Spitze
treffen möchte mit einer Kritik und
nicht das gleichmäßig verteilt aber
diejenigen die heute abend entscheidend
sein werden in den nächsten Wochen auch
wenn die Grünen sein sie werden
entscheiden wer am Ende hier als Sieger
am Ende die Regierenden Bürgermeister
stellen kann das über schwarz grüne
diskutiert wer wäre in anderen
Bundesländern wahrscheinlich ganz normal
hier sind die Welten ziemlich getrennt
ziemlich weit auseinander glauben Sie
dass der Brücken einfach gelingt ja weil
zu zweit man einfacher regiert als zu
dritt und das muss er sich überlegen
wenn man natürlich die Spitze selbst
stellen kann als grüne wird man das
versuchen auch zu dritt aber wenn die
Möglichkeit ist zu zweit zu regieren ist
das einfacher als zu dritt man kann viel
mehr von der eigenen Programmatik
umsetzen wir haben vorhin gehört Korte
das der CDU-Generalsekretär davon
gesprochen hat eine linke
Regierungsbildung sei unanständig
angesichts der Führung der CDU ist das
so nein oder soll unangemessen denn es
ist absolut legitim durch ein
sondierungsmeisterschaft geradezu auch
am Ende eine Mehrheit hinzubekommen wir
haben ihn jetzt in zehn Jahren Beispiele
zwischen 5 und 15%, dass der Sieger des
wahlabends nicht die regierungsbilden
konnte also es ist legitim das ist
berechtigt und es ist möglich dass
diejenigen die zweite werden auch am
Ende Sieger sein kann Professor Karl
Rudolf Korte für den Moment ganz vielen
Dank und jetzt hören wir schon die
Grünen werden
doch unter erheblichen politischen Druck
jetzt geraten sich eine möglichen bunten
Bündnis mit der CDU zu öffnen wir gehen
deshalb jetzt noch mal zu den Grünen und
zu schmiese mit einer Gesprächspartnerin
die auch schon mal Regierende
Bürgermeisterin werden wollte hier
bei mir ist jetzt Renate kühners einst
Spitzenkandidatin 2011 war das für das
Amt des Regierenden Bürgermeisters oder
Bürgermeisterin und
Bundestagsabgeordnete für Berlin dieses
Ergebnis ein bisschen ein Dejavue die
Grünen hätten Platz 1 haben können so
saß lange aus und nun wird es vielleicht
Platz drei Platz zwei Dejavue nee ich
bin voller Freude also wir haben unser
brillantes letztes Wahlergebnis gehalten
wir sind sozusagen gleich mit der SPD
zum jetzigen
umfragestand da bin ich erstmal ganz
stolz drauf wir sind ja eine Partei die
Veränderung will die sagt wenn es uns in
Zukunft gut gehen sollen müssen wir
Veränderung machen aber war das ein
gutes Ergebnis
aus sie könnten möglicherweise auch in
der gleichen Konstellation es fortführen
also
rot grün rot Herr schmiese jetzt sieht
es auch so aus als könnte es grün rot
rot geben also darauf werden wir noch
warten müssen aufgrund des Drucks der
letzten Zeit bin ich erstmal froh das
haben sie hier im Saal auch gesehen dass
wir dieses Bündnis rechnerisch
fortsetzen können und der Abend wird
zeigen ob wir innerhalb dessen die
Nummer eins sind alles klar das klingt
auch nicht dass die Schwarz-Grünen
präferieren vielen Dank erstmal Renate
Künast und damit zurück zu Bettina
schaust das stimmt denn wenn die Chance
bestünde die Regierende Bürgermeisterin
zu stellen dann ist das sicherlich dann
die Kombination der Wahl interessant
heute Abend und jetzt gucken wir uns
nämlich noch mal an die die
Wahlergebnisse der Grünen woher kommen
die Stimmen nee wir gucken erstmal auf
die Kompetenzen und eine kleine
Kompetenz der Grünen ist natürlich in
der gerade in der Großstadt das Thema
Verkehr und da hat sie interessanter
Entwicklung gegeben von 2021 bis 23
jetzt nämlich sagen 21% dass die Grünen
da die größte Kompetenz haben
2021 waren es noch 36 Prozent das heißt
in der Regierung haben sie 15 Punkte da
verloren und jetzt gucken wir noch mal
auf die wahltagsbefragung an den
Wahllokalen anonymisiert natürlich wer
wählte die Grünen nach Alter das können
wir schnell durchfahren wir sehen unten
die Gewinne und Verluste und wir sehen
vor allem in den absoluten Zahlen bei
unter 44 sind die Grünen mit 26% oder
bei unter 30 25% extrem stark und dann
bröckelt es je älter die Wählerinnen und
Wähler werden vielen Dank Matthias das
ist interessant das scheint so ein Trend
zu sein die Jüngeren Welten die Grünen
die
älteren Welten CDU das hat Probleme
gebracht für die SPD den
Bundesvorsitzenden begrüße ich herzlich
hier bei uns im waldstudio laskingball
ist bei uns ja nach mehr als 20 Jahren
verliert die SPD den Spitzenplatz in
Berlin im Moment gleich auf mit den
Grünen also noch nicht mal klar ob man
zweite Kraft ist wie enttäuscht sind sie
da muss man nicht drumherum reden das
ist kein schönes Ergebnis wir haben mit
Franziska Giffey und der Berliner SPD
für ein anderes Ergebnis gekämpft ich
habe mir ein anderes Ergebnis gewünscht
jetzt muss man heute Abend feststellen
die CDU liegt klar auf Platz 1 dazu
Gratulationen aber es geht jetzt
natürlich um die Frage wie sieht das
endgültige Wahlergebnis aus und welche
Optionen sind dann möglich und da bin
ich zugegebenermaßen ein bisschen
gebranntes Kind von der letzten Berlin
Wahl da war ich noch Generalsekretär der
ist mir um 18 Uhr gesagt worden die SPD
hat keine Chance am Ende kam es ganz
anders und deswegen warten wir jetzt mal
endgültig ab welche Option es gibt und
dann geht es um eine stabile Regierung
in Berlin zu bilden und das wird
spannend dann gucken wir uns einfach mal
den Abstand an da sind zehn Punkte
dazwischen die die CDU führt und die ähm
SPD muss zudem auch noch Verluste
zeitigen was glauben sie ist der
wählervilla aus diesem Ergebnis erstmal
muss man hier feststellen dass es in
Berlin Unmut gibt das habe ich selbst in
den letzten Wochen noch gemerkt wenn ich
hier in Berlin unterwegs unterwegs war
es gab ein Frust darüber dass diese Wahl
wiederholt werden muss es gibt
Herausforderungen in Berlin die
angepackt werden müssen das muss eine
neue Regierung jetzt auch anpacken also
das zeigen uns die Zahlen ja auch
deutlich aber es geht jetzt um die Frage
wer kann eine stabile Regierung in
Berlin bilden wie kann Regierungsbildung
hier aussehen wer hat am Ende doch
überzeugende Mehrheiten dann im
Parlament und das ist alles stand jetzt
noch völlig unklar also sie sagen im
Moment abwarten sprechen die Zahlen an
die können wir uns noch mal eben
zusammen angucken Analysedaten zum SPD
Wahlergebnis ja es ist ganz klar dass es
eine Wahl war die im Land entschieden
wurde und nicht von bundespolitischen
Themen das hat eine große Mehrheit der
Befragten uns immer gesagt deshalb
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an die
Bewertung
Spitzenkandidatin und der Partei
Franziska Giffey in diesem Jahr bei
dieser Wahl bei Plus 0,4 das ist ein
extrem schwacher Wert die SPD in Berlin
bei 0,8 2021 war nicht mal anderthalb
Jahren saß noch ein ganzes Stück besser
aus Franziska Giffey plus 0,9 und die
SPD 0,2 das heißt im Amt in diesen
anderthalb Jahren hat sowohl die
Kandidatin als auch die Partei hier
verloren und was war vorhin schon
gesehen haben es ist ja auch nicht
gelungen in diesen anderthalb Jahren so
richtig sich ein Amtsbonus zu erarbeiten
warum ist das nicht gelungen ja wir
wissen Sie Franziska Giffey ist ja in
der Tat erst knapp länger als ein Jahr
im Amt es war eine Zeit der großen
Krisen wenn Sie an alles das Denken was
für bundespolitisch zu bewältigen hatten
das muss ja auch im Land bewältigt
werden die Frage wie können
Energiekosten bezahlt werden wie es
überhaupt genug Energie da die Pandemie
war nicht vorbei und dann kam eben dazu
diese Frage der Wahlwiederholung für die
Franziska giffe nun überhaupt nichts
konnte sie hatte das zu verantworten
dass die Wahl jetzt gut organisiert
wurde das scheint ja geklappt zu haben
nicht mit dem Ergebnis dass ich mir
gewünscht habe aber sie hatte gar nicht
wie richtig viel Zeit die Dinge
anzupacken aber ich bin fest davon
überzeugt Franziska gefallen hat die
Leidenschaft für Berlin hat auch den
Elan und hat auch die politischen
Vorstellungen des Land voranzubringen
aber normal es geht jetzt um die Frage
wie können politische Mehrheiten
aussehen das ist gerade noch unklar da
wollen sie natürlich jetzt auch nicht
vorgreifen das ist nachvollziehbar aber
wenn man sich ein Szenario anschaut das
ist nämlich tatsächlich auch für
Schwarz-Grün reichen könnte Muster nicht
die SPD geradezu auch als Juniorpartner
in eine große Koalition einsteigen denn
sonst ist hinten der Opposition das sind
theoretische Diskussionen die jetzt noch
gar nicht stattfinden können ich bin
dafür dass die demokratischen Parteien
miteinander reden das wird auch so sein
dass man dann wahrscheinlich sehr
vielfältige Gespräch hat das haben wir
nach der Bundestagswahl übrigens auch
gehabt wo ein Armin Laschet ja von Platz
2 auch probiert hat dann eine Regierung
zu bilden das ist ihm nicht geglückt und
ich bin mir aber sicher dass Franziska
Giffey der sehr gute Gespräche führen
wird und wissen Sie wenn am Ende die
Möglichkeit besteht dass sie Regierende
Bürgermeisterin bleibt dass sie das Land
weiter voranbringen so wie sie das in
diesem ein Jahr getan hat dass man noch
Ziele umsetzt die für das Miteinander
dieser Stadt stehen die zum Beispiel für
den Wohnungsbau stehen die für eine
moderne Verkehrspolitik stehen dann
werden wir jetzt SPD diese Möglichkeit
auch ergreifen klare Worte vielen Dank
lass den Wald für den Besuch hier im
Wahlstudio so jetzt gehen wir mal einmal
ins Foyer denn ich höre das Franziska
Giffey jetzt auch den Weg hier ins
Abgeordnetenhaus gefunden hat schauen
wir mal einmal hier in dieses schöne
Gebäude nein da sehe ich Stefan
Merseburger und zwar ganz ohne Franziska
gefallen aber ja wartet darauf
wahrscheinlich Stefan ja das ist es wir
warten darauf dass Franziska Giffey hier
reinkommt und vorbei läuft und uns
vielleicht was sagen aber sie wird
sicherlich auch bei euch später ja noch
was erzählen die große Frage ist wie
wird sie reagieren ich glaube sie lässt
sich zeitweise eben eine Zitterpartie
ist und noch nicht wirklich entschieden
ist ob sie Platz zwei verteidigen kann
und damit den Anspruch auf das Rote
Rathaus und damit den Posten als
Regierende Bürgermeisterin und das ist
irgendwie bei dem obwohl der Sieg äh der
der CDU ja Haus hoch und klar ist ist
das noch mal die ganz ganz entscheidende
Frage an diesem Abend das ist die
oder eben nicht und was passiert wenn
Bettina jarasch vor Franziska Giffey
landet denn sie muss dann ja sozusagen
irgendwie den Posten als Regierende
Bürgermeister für sich reklamieren
Stefan Merseburger genauso ist es und
wir sind gleich dann bei dir wenn es
soweit ist können uns aber hier jetzt
noch mal sehr gerne unterhalten mit
Carsten Linnemann dem stellvertretenden
cdu-bundesvorsitzenden ja kein Wegner
ist der Wahlsieger des Abends die CDU
liegt sehr deutlich hier vorne und ähm
er sagt Berlin hat den Wechsel gewählt
ja CDU Sieg aber keine Mehrheit was nun
das muss man abwarten aber das ist ja
dieser tolls was in Berlin passiert alle
Daten zeigen dass nur noch ein Drittel
der Berliner sind optimistisch vor
wenigen Jahren waren es noch zwei
Drittel das können sie nicht negieren
wir sind hier in einer großartigen Stadt
die es noch nichtmals schafft eine
wahlanständig durchzuführen sie haben
schon gewonnen sie müssen sagen diese
Wechselstimmung die können sie nicht
einfach negieren und sagen die Menschen
wollen ja einen richtigen Wechsel und
deswegen gibt es einen klaren
Regierungsauftrag gut und auch einen
kleinen regierungsanspruch wie wir hören
hat kein ja am Ende aber doch im Vorfeld
jetzt ein bisschen versäumt schon mal
ein paar Orangen zu legen zu SPD und
Grünen die ihnen ja ihm jetzt die kalte
Schulter zeigen können überhaupt nicht
die Menschen sehen sich doch nach einer
klaren Aussprache was will ich und was
will ich nicht er hat klar gesagt er
will einen starken Rechtsstaat die
Vorschule wieder einführen damit Kinder
wenn sie eingeschult werden der
deutschen Sprache mächtig sind ein
verpflichtendes gesellschaftsjahr er hat
klare Standpunkte und das fehlt in der
Demokratie und jetzt muss man auf die
Partei hinzugehen und nicht im Wahlkampf
dieses kuscheln das führt nur dazu dass
es Demokratie Verdrossenheit gibt aber
demokratie heißt auch man muss
Mehrheiten haben zum Regieren das gehört
dazu Mario chaia ihr Generalsekretär hat
vorhin gesagt wenn rot rot grün oder rot
grün rot oder grün rot rot noch mal
versuchen werde eine linke
Mehrheitsregierung zu bilden sei das
unanständig ist das so dann wissen Sie
dieses Wahlergebnis zeigt doch dass die
Berliner einen Wechsel wollen also
entweder interpretiere ich die Zahlen
falsch aber das was ich den ganzen Abend
darüber man will einen Wechsel man will
kein weiter so da empfehle ich alle
demokratischen Parteien dieses
wahrzunehmen und anzunehmen und
miteinander zu reden und der in
Regierungsauftrag hat die CDU das ist
offenkundig Saat Carsten Linnemann der
stellvertretende Bundesvorsitzende
vielen Dank für den Besuch hier im
Studio
so jetzt schieben wir ein bisschen
Analyse CDU noch gleich hinterher denn
Matthias du hast interessante Daten ja
so sieht's aus welche Partei kann die
Probleme in Berlin künftig am besten
lösen also der Blick nach vorne und das
schauen wir uns hier an SPD 17 CDU 24%
sehr deutlich vorne das ist sicher eine
Erklärung für dieses Wahl sehr positive
Wahlergebnis für die CDU man muss dazu
sagen auf die Frage wie ist Berlin auf
die Zukunft vorbereitet sagen nur 19%
hier in Berlin gut das ist der
schlechteste Wert den wir jemals in
einem Bundesland gemessen haben noch ein
kurzer Blick auf die wahlstruktur wer
hat die CDU gewählt nach Alter und da
sehen wir sozusagen ein umgekehrtes Bild
gegenüber den Grünen vorhin je älter
desto mehr CDU-Wähler bei den über
60-Jährigen sind das satte 38% und hier
liegen auch die größten zu gewinnen mit
11 und 10 Punkten und hier bei den über
60-Jährigen hat die SPD auch deutlich
verloren
Dankeschön also die älteren Welten die
CDU und offenbar das haben wir vorhin
schon gesehen auch so mancher
FDP-Anhänger hat sich diesmal für die
CDU
entschieden deshalb gucken wir jetzt
noch mal auf die FDP denn für die bleibt
das ganze unsicher 5 % können auch 4,8
werden heißt das immer die der Abend ist
für die FDP noch lang und wir gehen zu
Nils Schneider der mit dem FDP Fraktion
gesprochen hat
bei mir ist Christian Dörr der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP im
Bundestag was sagen sie zu dem Ergebnis
wird ein spannender Abend auch für die
FDP ich bin der optimistisch was den
Wahlabend heute abend betrifft Berlin
wollte den Wechsel das sieht man davon
hat die Union der ich gratuliere zu
diesem guten Ergebnis mehr profitiert
als wir aber wir sind hoffnungsvoll
jetzt ist die Berlinwahl die erste von
vier Landtagswahlen in diesem Jahr für
die FDP sieht momentan nicht so gut aus
ist das ein gut also es kann ja kein
guter Staat für sie seine dieses Mal ja
also jede Landtagswahl ist anders in
Berlin ist ja das kann man ja mit Händen
greifen wirklich eine Wechselstimmung da
gewesen die Verkehrspolitik wenn Sie
daran denken oder die Tatsache dass die
Verwaltung nicht funktioniert für der
Senat schon verantwortlich ist dieser
rot rot grüne Senat deswegen sind wir
gespannt ob der wächst am Ende gelingt
und dafür braucht es natürlich auch eine
FDP im Abgeordnetenhaus insofern bin ich
optimistisch
sebastian hat einen tollen Wahlkampf
gemacht und jetzt schauen wir mal was
haben bringt bei dem vielleicht der
Rückenwind von der Bundespartei gefehlt
ist vielleicht ihre Performance in der
Bundesregierung nicht so gut dass das
hier
vorgeschlagen hat also wie gesagt jede
Landtagswahl ist anders und hier geht es
wirklich um die Berliner Themen das hat
man ja gesehen ich meine es musste eine
Wahl wiederholt werden weil die
Verwaltung nicht richtig funktioniert
hat wofür ich die Mitarbeiter
verantwortlich sind sondern die
Landesregierung und ich glaube dafür hat
die SPD am Ende auch eine Quittung
bekommen und jetzt schauen wir mal was
der Wahlabend bringt ich bin da weiter
optimistisch vielen Dank also das wird
noch ein langer Abend für die FDP danke
schön wir gehen noch mal weiter zur AFD
die sich Hoffnungen gemacht hatte hier
in Berlin wieder zweistellig zu werden
danach sieht es im Moment nicht aus 9 %
in der ersten Hochrechnungen wie wird
das diskutiert in der Kiste bei der AFD
also wenn es bei den 9% bleibt dann hat
die AFD ihr Wahlziel nicht erreicht denn
sie wollte ja die zweistelligkeit und
sie wollte ihre parlamentarische
Bedeutung definitiv steigern und
dementsprechend verhalten war hier auch
der Applaus um 18 Uhr größer war der
Applaus dann als die Spitzenkandidatin
Christian Brinker hier vor der eines
Mikrofon trat und bedanke sich bei allen
und sah das Ergebnis als Bestätigung
ihrer Politik die AFD wollte als eine
der ersten Parteien die Wahlwiederholung
und damit auch eine zweite Chance jetzt
muss sie sich fragen ob sie die auch
optimal genutzt hat ja Dankeschön den
Orchester für diese Eindrücke und jetzt
können wir mal schauen in der
schwierigen Koalitionsfrage die jetzt
für Berlin ansteht was eigentlich die
Präferenz der Berlinerinnen und Berliner
ist das finden die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner auch nicht so einfach haben wir
vorher gemessen und da sehen wir uns mal
eine Grafik an eine Koalition aus als
SPD grün und linken also der amtierende
Koalition finden gut gerade mal 30%
schlecht 52 %. eine Koalition aus CDU
und SPD 45% schlecht 38 % gut aber
immerhin noch ein Stückchen mehr als das
amtierende Bündnis CDU grün und FDP
finden nur 19% gut die FDP bräuchte man
ja gar nicht wie das heute abend Wissen
CDU und Grüne alleine haben aber
eigentlich ausgeschlossen miteinander
trainieren ja Dankeschön so das ist ein
etwas diffuses Bild car Rudolf Korte was
würden Sie daraus ableiten
Eindeutigkeit wählen aber uneindeutig
und das gibt immer komplexere
Koalitionen wie wir sie in anderen
Ländern ja auch kennen manchmal muss man
auf starten Neugründungen in Deutschland
warten um neue Flaggenfarben zu
entwickeln also wir haben ja nach wie
vor im Bundesrat 15 verschiedene Formate
und hier wird es auch ein langes Ring
mit der sondierungsweltmeister wird die
regierende Bürgermeister am Ende Stellen
nicht der automatisch der die meisten
Stimmen bekommen hat das ist ein
interessanter Gedanke denn so die Fuß
ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht denn
immerhin reicht ja womöglich schon eine
zweier Kombination die allerdings der
CDU Spitzenkandidat erstmal hinbekommen
muss was beginnt da jetzt für ein Mikado
wer sich als erster bewegt hat gewonnen
oder verloren als bei der
Regierungsbildung sind wir Zuschauer
erstmal und wir haben jetzt alles getan
abgestimmt idealerweise als Berlinerin
Berliner da sind wir Zuschauer aber ist
natürlich ein geben und nehmen es kommt
auch an welchen koalitionstyp man
anstrebt ob es eine Koalition ist der
Differenz der die Unterschiede sichtbar
macht auch belässt dafür auch Regeln
oder nur nach Schnittmengen nach
Gemeinsamkeiten sucht wir haben eine
Typenvielfalt insofern kommt es aber an
eine Kunst Gemeinsamkeit
herauszuarbeiten und auf
verhandlungsmöglich Taktik der nächsten
Tage und Wochen Verhandlungstaktik und
man hörte bei Kai Wegner dem cdu-spitzen
Mann vorhin schon so erste Anklänge dass
er schon kleine Hinweise an SPD und
Grüne gab dass man natürlich
partnerschaftlich eine Koalition bilden
wollen er muss sich jetzt tatsächlich
ein bisschen reinschmeißen oder ja ist
ein eine Verhandlungssituation bei der
man idealerweise den Kuchen ganz groß
macht und für jeden etwas dabei zu haben
da sind aber geübte Akteure im Spiel die
das auch machen werden da bin ich
ziemlich sicher so dass es nicht neu ist
so etwas auszuhandeln sondern sind
Professionalität im Spiel um das am Ende
zu einer Gemeinsamkeit zu überführen und
das ist im hier im Abgeordnetenhaus auch
wichtig denn man kann auch bei der Wahl
das sieht man hier wie die
Regierungsbildung vonstatten geht nicht
beliebig oft fehlen dann gibt es am Ende
Neuwahlen das hat diese Verfassung hier
festgelegt car Rudolf Korte vielen Dank
für den Moment wir sehen uns später noch
mal wieder und wir gehen jetzt noch mal
zur SPD
starke leichte nein jetzt kommen wir es
genau es sind leichte Verluste aber es
sinnverluste und vor allem ist das der
Abstand der CDU doch groß also mit
Abstand nur zwei stärkste Kraft im
Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus und jetzt ist
die Frage wie diskutiert dass die Partei
ähm soll man darauf beharren die
Regierung zu stellen vor allem dann
natürlich wenn man erster ist oder aber
sucht man das Gespräch oder ist man
bereit zum Gespräch mit der CDU die
diskutiert dass die Partei Ralf
Schipanski
bei mir ist Christian hegebruch von der
Fraktion zehn Punkte hinter der CDU kann
man da wirklich noch sagen man hat einen
Regierungsauftrag das ist auf jeden Fall
ein bitterer Abend für die Berliner
Sozialdemokratie die CDU hat hier den
deutlichen Wahlsieg errungen und das
müssen wir und werden wir
selbstverständlich anerkennen gleichwohl
ist es so dass die CDU auch ein sehr
spaltenden Wahlkampf geführt hat in
Berlin mit der Vornamen Debatte bleiben
wir jetzt mal bei der SPD und die CDU
hat nun mal zehn Punkte mehr als sie
aber können sie wirklich sagen wie
vorhin auf Franziska giffe die hier
stand wenn wir vor den Grünen sind
machen wir trotzdem weiter und versuchen
einen stabiles Bündnis zu schmieden wer
regieren will hat natürlich sofort das
erstmal den Aufgaben eine
regierungsfähige Mehrheit zu
organisieren das gehört zur Demokratie
und dann insoweit zur Wahrheit auch
immer dazu
gelingen ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass wir ein weiteren Verlauf des Abends
merken werden dass die SPD als
zweitstärkste Partei heute Abend ein
Wahlergebnis hat auch ganz kurz wie
enttäuscht sind sie sehr das war ganz
kurz und mit diesen Eindrücken zurück zu
dir ja danke schön bin Ralf stepanski zu
SPD und wir kommen noch mal zu den
Grünen die sich das natürlich heute
alles auch ein bisschen offen halten und
mit nuripur ist da der Grünen
Bundesvorsitzende ein Schwarz-Grün in
Berlin weil das nichts wir haben eine
klare Präferenz hattikuliert das ist die
Formation die bisher da ist nur dass wir
vorne sind das ist das was wir im
Wahlkampf immer gesagt haben es gilt
weiterhin natürlich müssen die
demokratischen Parteien alle miteinander
sprechen können aber die Inhalte müssen
passen und da bin ich sehr gespannt was
ihr Gespräch ergeben das liegt natürlich
bei unseren Freunden in Berlin das liegt
bei den Freunden in Berlin die jetzt
genauso wie sie noch darauf hoffen dass
das Rennen mit der SPD zugunsten der
Grünen natürlich ausgehen das warten sie
auf jeden Fall erstmal ab und dann wäre
das die Präferenz richtig
selbstverständlich und wir haben ja
Wahlkampf gemacht damit wir eine grüne
Regierende Bürgermeisterin ins Rote
Rathaus schicken können und
jetzt schauen wir mal ob wir Platz zwei
erreichen können mit Platz zwei wäre
nach dem bisherigen zahlen das war jetzt
hier tatsächlich noch machbar muss man
Gespräche führen schauen was passiert
wenn die CDU einlädt werden die Berliner
Grünen natürlich ist zum Gespräch gehen
und wir werden natürlich auch die
anderen demokratischen Parteien einladen
mit uns Gespräche zu führen die Grünen
haben in diesem Wahlkampf auf jeden Fall
Federn gelassen oder sagen wir mal in
diesen anderthalb Jahren kompetenzwerte
eher runter Vertrauensverlust wenn man
jetzt sieht die CDU so weit vorne kann
man daraus nicht eigentlich nur den
Schluss ziehen Berlin hat den Wechsel
gewählt ich kann der Berliner CDU und
Kai Wegner persönlich gratulieren zu
diesem Wahlergebnis aber in der
Demokratie muss man noch Mehrheiten
organisieren können wenn man Regierende
Bürgermeisterin Bürgermeister werden
will und es gab viele Fälle historische
bei denen das nicht zwingen der Fall war
Armin Laschet hat mit uns
Sondierungsgespräche geführt nach der
Bundestagswahl obwohl er nicht erster
war und wir haben die natürlich auch
angenommen also schauen wir mal was sehr
was die Gespräche geben
der Grünen Bundesvorsitzende danke für
den Besuch hier im Studio und wir haben
eine neue Hochrechnung die sehen wir uns
an
Frische Zahlen wichtig und die haben wir
hier die nächste Hochrechnung 18.54 Uhr
die SPD kommt demnach auf 18,2 Prozent
mit Verlusten die CDU kommt auf 28 %
gewinnt 10 Punkte dazu die Grünen
18,2%, die Linke kommt auf 12,8%, die
AFD auf 9,2% und die FDP nach wie vor
rund um die 5% andere 8,6 %. jetzt
schauen wir mal was das heißt fürs
Regieren im Roten Rathaus wer könnte
damit wählen 66 ist die Zahl der
abstellten Mehrheit so viel Sitze
braucht man für das amtierende
Dreierbündnis SPD Grüne und Linke reicht
das deutlich egal ob grüne oder SPD am
Ende zwei stärkste Kraft sind CDU und
SPD sehen wir bei 66 die hätten also
genau das Minimum was man braucht und
CDU und Grüne ganz genau so
eben auch auf 66 ein schneller blicken
auf die Wahlbeteiligung da sehen wir
66,9% 2021 parallel zur Bundestagswahl
natürlich höher
75,4 und jetzt bei 65 also noch etwas
niedriger als 2016
danke schön Matthias und wir haben vier
Minuten gut bis zu 19 Uhr heute Sendung
Carol of Contest bei uns ähm dann frage
ich sehr gerne mal haben sie schon ein
Gefühl trauen sie sich schon eine
Prognose trauen sie sich eine Prognose
zu wie es ausgeht
meine Prognose
bezieht sich darauf dass es zu zweit
einfacher ist als zu dritt zu regieren
man kann viel mehr von der eigenen
Thematik Programmatik unterbringen und
wir wissen auch dass die zwei
Koalitionen stabil zusammenarbeiten
anders zusammenarbeiten als Dreier das
ist eine ganz neue Herausforderung dass
einer nie in der Minderheit ist
gegenüber den anderen beiden das
schwierige Konstellation insofern wäre
meine Prognose dass es am Ende eine
zweier Koalition werden könnte das
Interessante ist einfach das
spektakuläre in dem das Wahljahr beginnt
aber die Verlässlichkeit auf deutsche
Wählerinnen und Wähler die mittig wählen
das ist ganz ungewöhnlich in seinem
krisenwindeln
vielen Dank vor 19 Uhr können wir jetzt
schon Franziska Giffey begrüßen die
bereits zu uns kommt ich darf Sie sehr
gerne bitten wir haben noch drei Minuten
bis zu 19 Uhr danke dass Sie schon kurz
vorher kommen und Frau gefallen
natürlich wir müssen uns die
Gretchenfrage für unsere
hauptnachrichtensendung aufsparen aber
ich will zunächst mal fragen nach mehr
als 20 Jahren ist die SPD nicht mehr
stärkste Kraft in Berlin
großer Abstand zugunsten der CDU wie
bitter ist für Sie persönlich dieser
Abend das ist natürlich eine schwierige
Lage für uns und man muss es ganz klar
sagen wir hatten eben diese
Wiederholungswahl sehr viel Frust bei
den Menschen eine krisenhafte Situation
die wir im letzten Jahr bewältigt haben
und auch eine Unzufriedenheit in der
Stadt mit Dingen die nicht gut gelaufen
sind und man muss natürlich ganz klar
sagen die CDU hat hier den ersten Platz
erzählt und ähm das ist ein deutliches
Zeichen der Berlinerinnen und Berliner
dass sie eben bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr
so weiter wollen dass Sie eine
Veränderung wollen und ähm egal wie das
Bündnis am Ende aussieht was dann eine
stabile Regierungsmehrheit auch
hinbekommt es muss sich etwas verändern
und ähm das bedeutet dass wir jetzt an
diesem Punkt erstmal ein Stück weit
abwarten müssen wie es mit Platz zwei
aussieht dann können wir erst bewerten
wie die SPD damit auch weiter umgehen
wird das heißt also bisher streichen Sie
die Segel auf jeden Fall nicht wenn ich
das richtig sehe
genau dass er auch zu früh aus meiner
Sicht bei der knappensituation das ist
deutlich das würden sie dann tun wenn
die Grünen vor ihnen liegen was meinen
Sie mit segelstreichen dass sie sich aus
dem Versuch diese Koalition vorzusetzen
verabschieden also zunächst einmal muss
jeder der das Rote Rathaus in
Regierungsverantwortung führen möchte es
schaffen eine stabile Mehrheit zu
organisieren auch Kai Wegener wird das
müssen und es ist jetzt an diesem Punkt
einfach zu früh zu sagen wie diese
Mehrheiten aussehen können aber ich habe
nur erlebt dass in den letzten Wochen
die CDU ja sehr viele Türen zugeschlagen
hat sowohl in Richtung der grünen als
auch in Richtung der SPD und wenn wir
eine Möglichkeit haben ein
Regierungsbündnis einzuführen unter
SPD-Führung dann werden wir auch
versuchen dafür eine stabile politische
Mehrheit zu organisieren so viel kann
man glaube ich jetzt auch schon sagen
ganz kurz vielleicht noch haben sie den
Eindruck ein bisschen zerrieben worden
zu sein die Jüngeren haben die Grünen